buenas noches lo que sigue a
continuación es formalizar su cargo como
nuevo presidente de perú por eso el
congreso ha programado para mañana una
ceremonia a las 4 de la tarde en la que
se le impondrá la banda presidencial a
esta situación que ha sido realizada el
día de hoy al culminar el acto sagasti
en su mensaje como jefe del parlamento
le pidió a los peruanos confianza y
aseguró que cumplirá todas sus promesas
también fue enfático en señalar que
trabajará por devolverle la esperanza a
los peruanos esto parecen ser parte de
los ejes que será en prioritarios en su
gestión que durará ocho meses olvidado
del acto
sagasti salió a los exteriores de la
plaza bolívar donde se congregaron más
de 1000 personas y el escenario fue
distinto al de ayer porque los
ciudadanos le brindaron muestras de
afecto y simpatía
sagasti también ha conseguido el
reconocimiento de la organización de los
estados americanos su secretario general
luis almagro le envió un saludo
deseo éxitos en su gestión como
presidente interino del perú francisco
le pregunto qué pasará ahora entonces
con el destituido presidente martín
vizcarra ya que el tribunal
constitucional decide en breve la
legitimidad de la vacancia presidencial
al que fue sometido
precisamente marianela ledezma
presidente del tribunal constitucional
efectúa una ponencia en la que tiene
preciso darle la razón a martín vizcarra
en su demanda competencial donde
sostiene que la vacancia presidencial es
ilegítima pero esta ponencia no propone
retornar lo en el cargo de presidente de
los peruanos que hará la decisión de los
juristas que integran el el tribunal
constitucional aceptar o rechazar esta
ponencia ellos se reúnen nuevamente este
miércoles y tomarán la decisión algunos
especialistas en materia legal sostienen
que si el fallo les es favorable a
martín vizcarra él puede usarlo para
interponer una nueva acción legal y
solicitar su reposición en el cargo de
presidente de los peruanos